oh thank you for the announcements it's
an honor for me to close off the stage
today of you're still a bit awake I'm
talking about my master thesis today
it's called computer-aided design of
advertisement products conversations so
yeah design I've never been that much in
design actually I mean you could tell in
fourth grade already that I was never
going to be the next Picasso data
science was more my thing I did my
bachelor industrial engineering at the
end of University of Technology there's
also a Big Data Honors Program next to
that and in the background you see the
very first group of students that
started at jets so I did my master data
science an intrapreneur ship now
finishing it up at at Greenhouse group
for my master thesis and for those one
ring that's me
so I'm now at greenhouse group it's a
digital marketing company which has five
digital marketing companies under it so
it's an umbrella company maybe you know
some of those but they also have
multiple hubs and one of them is the
creative hub and they make these kinds
of advertisements so these are products
compositions for clad fat who knows crud
fat my hands was the shops of crackpots
so the did they make a lot of these and
the grandfather also has nine hundred
and thirty stores across the Netherlands
it's even more than over time so they
make fifteen campaigns a week at
greenhouse group not only product
conversations but also other
advertisements of course so yeah there's
a lot of there's a lot of room for two
yeah improve this process so you see
these advertisements for example on new
data now
but now these advertisements are still
for a large part made by hands so this
is how the process looks like they read
the credits requirements they copy a
previous template they sort the images
out they load them into Photoshop and
then they skill the images correctly so
a lipstick should be smaller than a
mascara for example then they composed
them so they make a product composition
they put a pancake on the corner of the
composition for example two plus one for
free and then they then they see if it
works they they check if if it feels
right and otherwise they change things
around and then they apply reflection
and drop shadow and then they sent it to
crowd spot and then crowd spot gives
their opinion about it and yeah this
process goes back and forth so I'm going
to talk to you today about composing the
images so this was the ID I needed to
train some sort of model that takes
these images sprinkle some magic on it
and make a product composition not only
this sort of composition of course but
also other kinds of compositions and
yeah so this was my initial reaction I
never even heard of an algorithm do
doing something similar like this so
yeah how do we start as a data scientist
you of course start with data so there
are 200 compositions we're available in
the data set those were Adobe Photoshop
files but also the exported image files
so the dot JPEG files and the goal of
using data is then to extract some sort
of composition design rules or features
from the images to learn from so
starting off with the Adobe Photoshop
data you can try to extract the layers
that are actually important for the
composition so you remove the pancake in
the background and a class 4 logo for
example yeah so extract the compositions
but those files were really big it feels
a bit weird to say that
because we all love Big Data of course
but those files were really big were 1.2
gigabytes per composition and they also
had lack of proper naming conventions so
he didn't so you see here that there's a
layer called shampoo another one is
called spray conditioner oh but the
others are not really
yeah they don't really say what's in
there so it's it's hard to write rules
to actually extract the compositions
from there and also there's not really
proper tooling available in python you
exempt for example have PSD tools but
the functionality of that package is
really limited so yeah this was
infeasible this was deemed infeasible we
could also use the dot JPEG files so to
extract features from that you can use
some sort of transfer learning so I use
the PG t19 conclusion on neural network
with the weights trained on image net
then if you remove the last layer then
you still have to get the features and
you can use those to make make an image
so those images are now plotted using
tease me which is a dimensionality
reduction algorithm but you can see that
lots of values attached to similar
images but then in attributes that don't
matter for the composition so you see
the green background or the darker
border or the the red background of
course so this was also deemed
infeasible to actually extract
composition rules from so yeah how do we
start
apparently not with data so we need to
find some sort of other solution so we
can try to incorporate designers in the
process so I'm now going to talk about
how we can learn from designers there's
a research field called computer-aided
design it's not really explored much but
I stumbled upon this research that
in which you can make a furniture layout
using computer-aided design so you can
select a couch and two chairs for
example and then it can create lots of
variation for you so you can see what
you like and what you eventually select
so a lot of these methods make use of
genetic algorithms so a genetic
algorithm is a machine learning
algorithm based on evolution and the
natural selection so you can see that
the animal in the middle can reach the
leaves in the tree and the other stones
so the middle will survive and
eventually reproduce and the rest of the
population will then adapt to it so what
are the steps in a genetic algorithm you
initialize the population you perform
evaluation then the selection crossover
for a mutation and I will explain that
using a simple example in the same field
so we initialize the population of free
you see the the pantyliners packaging
here then you perform some evaluation so
assume that you want to plot all the
items on the the bottom of the image so
this line is it's a really simple
example you can do this by hand but just
for the for this example now so you
calculate the distance between the the
bottom of the packaging and this line so
you can see that the middle one is the
best then you perform some selection so
let's say you get rid of the most with
the one with the most value so the least
fittest one and then you perform
crossover so these these two merge and
create creates a child so it gets the
items to the left from the middle one
and the other from the top one and then
you apply some mutation so you add some
noise to the population so for example
these two you apply some noise to them
and then you repeat the loop until you
find some satisfactory design so we did
an initial experiment with designers
they get these components in the cloud
for canvas and they needed to make a
conversation and this was the outcome of
the designers so they all created a
different one so there's not actually
one solution to this problem there's not
one composition that actually satisfies
designers so we came up with the
research design in which we make use of
an interactive genetic algorithm and I'm
going to explain what an interactive
genetic algorithm is right after this
slide so we make a web application
designers use it and then they give
their feedback and we did this loop four
times so they could criticize the the
compositions that we made using our
genetic algorithm and then they could
give feedback so we improved product
four times and then in the end we did a
pairwise comparison research in which
five pairs of compositions are shown and
one of each pairs a computer-aided
design and the other is made by a
designer so going to share some results
with you today as well so what's an
interactive genetic algorithm it's
basically the same as a normal genetic
algorithm but then the selection is not
done by yeah some sort of predefined
rule but it's user selection so some of
these you do this for example 100 times
and every 10th generation you let a
designer select with the compositions
that move to the next generation
so how can we learn from designers we
use interactive genetic algorithms to
let them stare the evolution in the
right way so they they can find a
solution that satisfies them but what do
we actually learn from designers the
solution was implemented in peyten using
deep the genetic options were
implemented there and pillow was used
for the image processing and then we
made a web interface it's run on an AWS
ec2 instance and we use the really
simple tools like flask and JavaScript
paging the images is done by the
top-left corner so you see that free
bottles are pasted on the canvas using
this methodology and also the ones but
that are placed higher are pasted first
so that not for example the one that's
higher get based it in front of the
other one how do you initialize a
population of all random the canvas is
1200 by 628 so if you have for example
have 4 items then they are pasted
between 100 and 1200 for the
x-coordinate or it should be left
honored actually and then between 100
and 500 for the y-coordinate so that
they are actually not off canvas so that
you cannot see them and you repeat the
cycle until the population is filled so
for example 100 then the fitness of
composition is based on multiple
components so you loop over every item
and you check its attributes and those
attributes are overlapped with your with
the other items so it should be not too
much but also not too little so that you
see white space which is actually the
next attribute so you should not be too
much white space behind the conversation
because that looks ugly enough space to
the bottom and the side but also not off
canvas sorry you should see them because
if you add noise they could spin off the
canvas of course no floaters so for
example if you have an extra item and
should not flow
so that it cannot fly of course and
small items should always be in front so
the smaller jar should be in front
otherwise it gets covered by a bottle
and you cannot see it anymore so how do
you select the compositions if the user
does not select them you can use methods
called tournament selection so you
select K individuals as random from the
population you pick the one with the
best fitness you repeat until the
population is filled again so here you
have an example you pick three random
candidates from the population and then
you choose the winner and then you can
yeah you use those winners to fill up
the population again so you can get
duplicates in there and if those cross
over it will actually be the very same
conversation then cross over you have a
methods called two-point crossover so
you have two two parents those both have
x and y coordinates for the four items
and then you create the children by
merging those two like the genes from
the the parents to create children so
you create two children now then a
mutation which is actually the most
important part of this whole application
of genetic algorithms those are based on
component similarity which was feedback
by designers because similar component
should be grouped together I will cover
that later as well and hi different so
for example the smaller jar should not
be pasted behind a bigger bottle so one
step of mutation is at noise to the
coordinates of the item so you can see
the jar that is going some other
direction or aligning two items
vertically so putting them on the same
line align two items horizontally so now
it's actually in the back but for other
compositions just like the the Viceroy's
one I showed you in the beginning this
could be FL it's a mutation step you
could also mirror two items so they get
this
distance to the border and also the same
distance to the the bottom border
connect them together which actually has
the most probability in the algorithm I
implemented or shuffling them so you
swap the positions of the items then the
web application which is shown really
shortly here so you click the generate
button you select the designs you like
and you can also save them so they don't
get removed when you generate again you
see some other compositions and you can
export one and also visual effects are
already applied here so they don't have
to do that themselves designer so yet
this is also what we launched every week
and the designers give get feedback on
the loading time is a bit longer but I
skip this through for you so the main
learnings from designers some some
learnings are not shown here align the
composition in the middle so this was a
result of one of the first compositions
it's clearly not in the middle it should
be there you need to show variation
between conversations so in the first
launch designer came to me said I want
to choose one but they are all the same
and I would like them so the children
will also look the same so he can't get
any forehead head no floaters which I
also explained so components can go
flying and similar items need to be
grouped together just like in this one
that the two to the rights are actually
the same shape so we use the obviously
feeder to calculate shape similarity so
that they are grouped together with a
higher probability so yeah what can we
learn from designers I just presented to
you now what are the results after four
iterations I showed you this slide
before but now I
swap two out with computer aided designs
so I numbered them as well and the raise
of hands I'd like to know which one you
think is computer-aided or not so who
thinks one two three four pi and six so
actually one and three are computer
aided and the rest is made by a designer
so for lane four for people that don't
have a lot of design knowledge the the
difference is really little but defining
designers will actually see the result
the will see the difference here so for
designers it's not really satisfying but
the result for normal people is already
there the next steps is finishing up the
pairwise comparison so I did a little
test already with 50 respondents and
about 35 percent of the computer aided
designs were chosen over the designer
compositions so that's quite a lot quite
a result already applying official
effect so we working together with a
software engineer and he already managed
to put some really nice reflection on
the composition which is necessary for
credit spot and also going live with
this product so measuring the CTR on a
website like noodle Tinnell for example
so the takeaways from this presentation
start simple do basic test to find out
what methods are actually feasible
before spending too much time on them
test and talk so involve designers in
the process of developing such an
application so that he can get feedback
during the development and also a bit
words on this conference but design your
first
and data science seconds thank you very
much thank you very much for your talk
it wasn't it simply explains questions
thank you for a presentation and I have
a question about one it's different
number of her dad's in the picture your
input size is different do you view the
same model a different model for
different purpose you can use the same
exact model for that because it doesn't
it takes into account the number of
elements that are in there but yeah it
skills with them so you just initialize
a population that is bigger like the
genes in the population are bigger
what you call this really a creative
process because it seems you've just
shown that what the designers do is not
creative it is boring well did you
clarify they also think it's really
boring so they allowed me and my
colleagues to automate this because they
actually want to try to or they want to
do other work like branding campaigns
which are more exciting than this work
it's this whole process creative
it's just implementing rules but the
designers can still steer the genetic
algorithm in a direction they want so
they are shown a lot of variation and
from this variation they can choose a
composition they like and also if crowd
spot doesn't like that kind of
composition they can swap it out for
another one really quick so the pairwise
comparison is a test where five pairs of
compositions are shown to an internet
user and he or she selects the design he
likes but in practice it's never the
case did you see two compositions but
with the what I said here with going
life we're actually gonna do two
compositions by placing them on a on a
website not at the same time of course
and then measure CTR for example to see
which one does better
not yet that's really something that
could be for the future what do you mean
by random feedback randomizing the
selection process and and what then I'll
get a get a baseline
yes so you mean incorporating the CTR
for example in the fitness function yeah
this could be done did this is really
some explorative research it's never
been done before it's also for my master
thesis so this is the sculpt now but we
can also extend it later one two oh okay
I was wondering if you asked the
designers if the algorithm gave them new
ideas for designing these things that I
wouldn't have gotten otherwise didn't
get that feedback yet but they are
presented with a lot of variation you
could also see with the outcome of the
designers with the initial experiment
they all make a different design so for
today some designers gave the feedback
that they did not find the design that
they liked but they find another
satisfactory one so that's what some
feedback that was given
any other questions well I guess that's
it thank you very much guy yes give me
wrong about
[Applause]